[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking welcome to basic
fighter maneuvers
as briefed today's exercise is dog
fighting guns only no missiles
we do not go below the hard deck of 5
000 feet
working as a team you have to shoot me
down or else or else what sir
or else i shoot back
if i shoot either one of you down you
both lose this guy needs an ego check
we'll see that
he put some skin in the game
[Music]
whoever gets shot down first have to do
200 push-ups guys
that's a lot of push-ups well uh they
don't call it an exercise for nothing
sir you got yourself a deal gentlemen
light's on let's turn and burn
fanboy you see him nothing on the radar
off ahead he must be somewhere behind us
let's try not to get fired on the first
day tally down the county merrick's
coming in right
hey back where's your wingman
where are you i got you back i'm coming
hang in there hang in there hurry up man
hurry up
look at that breakfast
rooster just saved your life fellas but
it's gonna cost
not this time old man
[Applause]
[Music]
should be us down there
but it's not
and now you know a little something
about rooster
games that selfie wasn't it damn
how's about we tell everybody bob stands
for something other than robert i mean
don't take the bait bob want to know why
we call him hangman all right i got it
baby on board
greetings aviators my time
all right phoenix let's take this guy
out watch your back phoenix
where's he going that's why we call him
hangman he'll always hang you out to
drive
leaving your wingman there's a strategy
i haven't seen in a while he's called
you a man phoenix you gonna take that so
long as he doesn't call you a man
talk to me bob where's maverick his nose
is already coming around
me hangman for all you folks at home
this is how you bury a fossil all right
man time to teach you a lesson you're
out phoenix
let's go man let's see what you got come
get me
he will be gone
[Music]
79
[Music]
lights out coyote
copy
[Music]
here we go
in three
two
come on
[Music]
everyone
you